ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Hello and welcome
to Google Developers Live.
My name is Arun Nagarajan.
And I'm from the Google Apps
Developer Relations Team.
And today we have a
special guest, Gliffy,
that's going to be joining
here in the studios.
And they've actually built
a great Google Docs add-on
that they're going
to walk us through.
But before we dive into some
of the demos and details,
let's actually let them
introduce themselves.
I have Lyubov and Han.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Hi, I'm a
software developer at Gliffy.
And I've been working on the
add-on for about a month now.
And it's been really great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Awesome.
HAN LEE: I'm Han Lee.
I'm a product lead at Gliffy.
And I've been
working with Lyubov
to get our app put together.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
And for the folks that are
not familiar with Gliffy,
can you give me a background
on what the company does?
What the product is?
HAN LEE: Sure.
Absolutely.
Gliffy is a fast and
easy-to-use diagramming tool.
We were founded in 2005 and
we're the world's first NET
native diagramming app.
We started out in Flash
and imported to HTML5
about a year and a half ago.
Because it's HTML5,
Gliffy works on platforms
anywhere where
Chrome is supported.
So, Mac, PC, Linux, Chrome, OS.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great,
HAN LEE: And
personally, I really
love working with
the HTML5 technology.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Awesome.
And who's the typical
user of Gliffy?
HAN LEE: It varies a lot.
So we support a number
of diagram types.
A typical diagram would be
a flow chart like this one.
An ERD diagram, like this.
Or fun diagrams-- this is
something one of our users put
together for a
diagramming contest.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
Very cool.
All right.
So why don't we
actually take a look
at the actual add-on,
and then we'll
kind of dig in to some
of the technical details
and talk a bit about some of
the experience you've had.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: OK.
So, we have a Gliffy
menu dropdown.
And if you have
existing diagrams,
all you gotta do is
just click on Find.
And it'll pull up a list
of the recent diagrams
that you've been working on.
And you can insert it
directly from there.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: And you
can always browse by folder
if you have diagrams saved off.
There's also a search feature.
And then you could also
edit the diagrams directly
from the sidebar.
And it'll open up
the Gliffy interface.
The full-featured interface.
Additionally, you could create
a new diagram from Google Docs.
And that will offer
you some templates.
And after you create it,
and then you would save it,
and you would be
able to, hopefully,
see it in the document.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And this is just another
tab in your browser?
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Exactly.
And then once it successfully
saves, if you go back to this,
it will refresh every 30 seconds
and you will be able to see it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So it's like just
checking behind the scenes
for new documents?
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So you don't have to really
think about it too much.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK:
It basically pulls
in all the recent
diagrams, assuming
that you might want one.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
There it is.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Yay!
And then you can go
ahead and insert it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
I like the way you've done
the overlay menus there.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Yeah.
Bootstrap helped.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So that actually gets
to our next point, which
is can you talk a
little bit about some
of the technologies you've used?
Some of the internals
of how this all works?
What some of the
salient points are?
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Yeah.
So, the technical
background, it's
very simple for this add-on.
We have a few HTML
templates that we use.
And just one controller that
actually governs and takes
care of all the HTML templates.
And, of course, we
have the server script
that talks to the Gliffy server.
That's pretty much it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And you've used Bootstrap here
for the styling and everything?
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Yeah.
Bootstrap was a big savior.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK.
That's great.
And are there special
considerations
you guys took into effect
for the sidebar design
from a UX standpoint?
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: We had
our designers help us out
to make sure that it lays out
and it reflects, basically,
the Gliffy interface as well as
matches what Google might want.
So a lot of the
buttons are actually
very similar to
your Share button.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good call, yeah.
Very nice.
What are some of the interesting
challenges you ran into?
Some of the things
that gave you grief
or was complicated that
you could share with us.
HAN LEE: For me it
was really easy.
Lyubov did all the hard work.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
I'm sure there were
some interesting challenges.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK: Yeah.
So we did have some Caja
limitations that we ran into.
I wasn't expecting to not
have certain things available.
But the workarounds were
usually very simple.
And just required a little
bit of investigation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
What would be your advice
to other add-on developers,
other developers that
are interested in writing
other tools for
Google Docs or Sheets?
LYUBOV KASSIANIK:
I would advise them
to make a UI heavy
application and to limit
the script to just
the bare bones.
Mainly because a UI
heavy add-on would
mean a more responsive
user experience.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And by that you mean, do
more things in JavaScript
from the sidebar itself.
That's great.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK:
Sometimes that meant
I would write hidden
HTML elements that
would store some data.
But it was such a
worthwhile trade-off.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Interesting.
Versus going back to the
server and fetching something.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
So when you launch
this, what are
some of the interesting
success metrics
that you'll be tracking?
What are some of the things
that would mean important launch
milestones for you?
HAN LEE: That's
a great question.
I'm very metrics-focused.
So one key one would be the
percent of our regular users
that actually used the apps.
So that'll give us an idea of
the popularity within our user
base.
Another one is the
conversion rate of new users.
So we would take
a look at people
coming in through
the marketplace built
into Google Docs.
And compare the conversion
rate to our other ecosystems.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
That's great.
I've had a fun time
using the add-on myself.
Gliffy is a really
fun to use tool.
It's one of those tools
that you just open a tab
and start sketching.
It's great for brainstorming.
Great for architecture diagrams.
For software systems
and things like that.
Google has Google
Drawings, but I
feel like Gliffy has got
some really good templates
and really good
capabilities that I think
is useful for anyone
in any industry.
So best of luck with the launch.
I urge you all to go test
this and try this add-on.
And thank you very much for
being in the city with us.
LYUBOV KASSIANIK:
Thank you so much.
HAN LEE: Thanks, Arun.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.